greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by on it
listen whether it's [ __ ] alpha brain a
shrimp tech sports room tech immune
[ __ ] the whey protein the Mexican
chocolate protein listen top-notch you
understand me I've never never rarely
ever done business with a company that
they're [ __ ] there they're number one
product how for brain if you don't like
it don't refund and they don't want the
product back who does that when was the
last time your drug dealers did that
never gonna calm right now look at the
great list of supplements they have
there's something you like check out on
the way out this little box press in
church CH you are CH and get 10% off
your order delivered right the house no
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay number two listen
your Joey I'm thinking the joining
digits are way hundred pounds where do I
get a key from Omar the [ __ ]
shoemaker no Fuji sports.com tougher
than [ __ ] debt Fuji you understand me
but knocking people out with karate
chops since the for Nagasaki not to go
there not [ __ ] around listen people
tug on me they try to pull the sleeve to
put me to take my back nothing the
[ __ ] sleeves are intact
the keys are tough with a bit C
all-purpose ninety $86 G or the [ __ ]
super Otto which is one of my favorites
the new Seiko STI ko 2.0 is a savage the
elemental is a [ __ ] nice light key
right now in the summer where all you a
million in the Midwest go to Fuji
sports.com right now press ENTER CH BAM
10% delivered right to the [ __ ] house
you understand man you're looking sharp
and it's not just easy that's rash
guards if they fit me they fit you
because I'm a Fed [ __ ] go to Fuji Sports
calm right now press ENTER CH kick this
[ __ ] mule lead the way welcome to the
Church of what's happened uncle Joey
here first off if you came telling you
the shows and wise guys this weekend in
Salt Lake City I applaud you there with
great [ __ ] shows because of you guys
and number two I'm back you noticed if
he came to the shows I'm [ __ ] back
there's no more [ __ ] safety nets
there's no more nothing I'm back out of
my [ __ ] coma but I was in for six
months but I want to thank the club I
want to thank Keith and I want to thank
the [ __ ] great waitstaff
one of the hottest [ __ ] waste a for
women in the country even even Kate
Gregory on the way out she goes those
[ __ ] girls were throwing Heat but
they were great there was no problems
last night something I punched the
hostess chick in the face Linton and the
guy had a [ __ ] choke him up the other
comedian big props to him choke the guy
out to the cops got there there's always
some type of church drama always some
[ __ ] guy comes and Confused anyway it
was a great show great [ __ ] show
great weekend I applaud you guys and I'm
just happy to say I'm back guys and I'm
basically back because of you guys cuz I
thought about that i was just cheating
you guys lately like i just been trying
to be some plants safe and i'm worried
about the audience i went up there with
stories i haven't talked about in
[ __ ] 30 years yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore because i
was thinking about where i started doing
comedy okay and i always tell people
that it was in prison no it wasn't it
was number one bus from jersey city the
[ __ ] none guesses our job was to make
the bus driver pull over and quit that
was our job on a [ __ ] daily like for
him to pull over and go knock it off
guys we would ring the buzzes we would
deal with people we would shoot [ __ ]
spit balls at people or we would come go
on the bus and open up with the [ __ ]
opening theme from The Odd Couple right
off the bat but but people didn't know
was in Jersey City at the time there was
a methadone clinic and that's where
you're going to get off heroin and it
gives you the same symptoms as heroin so
people would get on the bus in Jersey
City then we get on the bus on 38th
Street and they'd be nodding on the
heroin with drool on their lip onto the
newspaper [ __ ] hilarious she can't
even write this [ __ ] and you even mess
with them on all of us we would get on
the bus and we just start giggling and
[ __ ] and then the guy would look at us
and like go can't you see I'm trying to
read the paper but one time I went on
one of those buses and I farted oh and I
woke the guy after he opened his eyes
like he saw a dragon he's like man no
father he goes just know I subtle
crawled up somebody's ass and died
something we [ __ ] down what are you
talking people on heroin like falling
asleep in the middle of the street
you're saying your fart woke one of them
up one of them up that was nodding
you know the benches of the sideways
right like he was sitting I mentioned
the back of the bus [ __ ] nodding off
and we were across and giggling Adam
he wouldn't wake up and I finally
dropped the bomb on him he [ __ ]
opened up his eyes really slowly I'll
never forget Delhi he looked around like
where he was and he said wonder [ __ ] is
that smell that's when you know you were
having issues yeah so I was just
thinking about like you know you're in
the green room and you're sitting in you
have like this list in your head that
you're gonna say and all of a sudden
that thought came into my mind and I
said just one up on stage around with it
then the one night I was talking to
Keith the club owner and me and Keith
have been on the road together since
1990 [ __ ] supposed to be a comic yeah
he stole a car but keeps a great comic
he's just a clean comic and he does
corporates but Keith's a a great guy and
whatever my contest we did 94 that's why
I saw Bill Cosby that's when he said
that not to do dirty calmly that Eddie
Murphy that was the time we're talking
about that we were talking about the
room in Salem that the time I want and I
told me what Salem was one of the best
nights of my life I get there to the
hotel with Jody this girl she's
featuring for me and her father my
father lived in Corvallis so we stopped
and picked him up so he can watch his
daughter before him and he want to go
out and drink with us we get to the
hotel he gets his own hotel room she
gets her own hotel room I got my whole
note down when we walk in I swear to god
this gotta be 300 [ __ ] kids with
balloons it's the National room I told
you when we're talking about Jody I
don't remember this on yeah one of those
kids did Special Olympics know what she
went dancing with balloons oh yeah and
we checked them and we're like wow these
kids got balloons holy [ __ ] you know it
wasn't there like I didn't even think
about in a bad way till that night Jody
because in all those towns when you do
some Leah and I were just talking about
one year recently have to go on the rail
if Lee really wants to do comedy now
comes the second part of this phase like
I was thinking what I'm doing today is
because of what I did 90 like is that
the weirdest thing it's not because of
what I did from 2000 to 2010 that's not
why I'm doing as well as I'm doing as
well as I'm doing today guys a comedian
like as a comedian as the art I'm doing
well as a comedian
not because what I different mm the 2010
at the Comedy Store that honed the art
it was what I did between 95 and 2000
which was I threw myself across the
country in two different markets and I
had just admire to those markets and
there's some markets that you just can't
adjust you're active and I mean you just
can't I mean you just can't they just
and in the back of your head you're so
an experience that you really don't see
it's not a knock against you was a knock
against me I had the same problem like
after I went to Nashville I knew never
go back to the Bible Belt like ten years
ago you come to me your joy I got a room
for you in Alabama listen bro no matter
how hungry I am I'm not taking that gig
because I'll tell you well I'm just I'm
not flying cross-country too Bob there
was a period that there was a period
where I bomb in the south and I don't
not in the south but in the upper south
not in Texas but it's the Bible Belt
south oh wow and then I had this other
thing to do comedy in front of people
with white hair so if I looked at the
curtain I saw somebody with white hair I
would [ __ ] panic and eat a big dick
on stage I had to get over that you know
how I got over that by going to all
those [ __ ] towns where there's a lot
of old people it shows so what you're
saying when you are saying this oh
between 90 and 95 or 95 or 2000 I'm
sorry did you go there knowing you were
gonna bomb I went there thinking about
the glamour of comedy getting the cold
reality of what it really was right that
yeah exactly like preparing me for what
it really was like you have to eat this
five bad years of Dec like it was five
years of rough deck like Winnemucca
Nevada
you know Billings month I'm not saying
these towns are bad in any way I'm just
saying that 30 years ago you know a town
beaut beaut Montana was I don't know how
what the population is taught but it
wasn't that 20 years ago and a guy like
me going up on stage talking about
eating [ __ ] didn't do well as a [ __ ]
feature act in none of those towns
whether it was Beauty Anna whether it
was somewhere in [ __ ] Utah whether it
was Ogden Utah and me a bag of dicks
there so you have to learn
all these markets you know you have to
go to all these places you have to go by
the Canadian border up in North Dakota
in South Dakota and see how you do there
and they eat this fish called walleye
okay first it's a fish that they eat up
there these people are pie it like the
Dakotas and Minnie butter soda and all
that it's just weird you learn their
traditions you know I still remember
going to each bar me up in the up in
northern Michigan you know there's an
island called Traverse City up there and
like I did the festival of cherries I
did gay pride in Michigan like who look
at me for gay pride in nineteen no in
2001 I did gay pride and Grand Rapids or
something like that for fifteen hundred
bucks like I went out I got on a bus and
just there's a part in Charlie where you
have to really and I told you this that
this prepare yourself for this I don't
see you preparing yourself for this that
for you to really dive in you have to
dive it it's a very tough dive so
looking like we're doing most people
don't believe in the dive and you have
to consume yourself with this you have
to get your car get it ready learn how
to get working on the road calling small
Booker's getting small Booker's getting
a headshot getting a 10-minute tape you
know I sure I thought I thought let's do
you over there right now right now you
do is what you have to start thinking
about in a year okay in a year when
you're doing comedy eighteen months
you're at a precipice if you've really
[ __ ] done cow have you really really
really in your heart have gone out there
every night done comedy at the two-year
mark you really start to think of where
this is going why am I doing this I'm
not making any real [ __ ] money
my mother's mad at me my girlfriend
doesn't like when I leave the house at
night there's so many [ __ ] things
that and those are the years that
toughen you up and you're not gonna like
what you gotta do you know you're not
gonna like eating six no doses and
drinking a [ __ ] gallon of Diet
Mountain Dew so you could drive all
night to get back here to do the podcast
Sunday at eight o'clock with no sleep
right like it's that type of [ __ ] like I
would drive all night to pick my
daughter up on son
two in the afternoon right like who
wants to drive all night to see their
[ __ ] kid after you haven't seen him
all week but that's the situations
that's the sacrifice that you know goes
with all this
I'm not when I get a check in the mail
now I don't look at it and go whoo I'm
getting away with murder
no I did my [ __ ] work right cuz I
even called you because I had to take a
quick ride this weekend and we're only
four and a half five hours tops tops and
I like it I like driving at that's not
the problem but the process of thing the
thing that I was blown away by was then
you have to get up and do comedy it's
not you get the other day before and you
get to chill out it's like usually eight
hours of driving when we talk about
those triple runs which people are
notorious I thought him Keith and I
spoke about the owner Eliza hasn't got a
great guy we spoke about how today you
know he's like what you're doing out
there is because of what you did yours
do you imagine that I go I never looked
at it that way that it really is like
going to a job and punching it like even
if you get ten dollars for a gig and
they make you do 30 minutes and you know
you're getting robbed that's part of the
[ __ ] gig you know you normally towns
you go to and let's say you have a gig
and you're getting 75 miles at that gate
well the [ __ ] MC also has a rock club
at midnight they don't pay you 25 bucks
oh [ __ ] okay you could sleep there if
you want on the bar I mean there's just
so many things but you're not gonna know
it unless you go out there it goes back
to meet up putting your hands in the
universe and going and I'm doing this
I'm doing this in some way or another
the universe is gonna take care of it
and we thing starts happening and you go
[ __ ] you know weird things start to
happen
you're gonna flat tire you change it it
cost you sixty five hours because you
gotta tow the car but then you go to a
town and you have a three-day night to
wait between gigs right and you're
looking at a $60 a night hotel that
people have gotten stabbed down they
yell review and the electric goes out
you can hear the mice at night
but the first day at the club the owner
of the club went to have a seat and he's
got a house to the basement you know him
as I am and now it's a Sunday and
instead of you've been in a shitty
[ __ ] hotel room you're actually in
somebody's basement with three other
guys from Emerson that are older than
you and they're talking about football
and they're from Boston and you're like
look at this [ __ ] am I the luckiest guy
in the world
I'm saving 60 bucks a night it's like
being with Geico it's like me with
[ __ ] Geico you're like I'm saving 60
bucks a night and these guys I'm not
sitting in a hotel room now this doesn't
happen every week this doesn't happen
every week but it doesn't happen unless
you try unless you're okay and it's
crazy because I think a lot of people I
remember when I first took my first
business trip I was so excited I felt
like a real adult but I got a hotel room
there's not many jobs that would tell
you hey you have to come out of town for
this but you're responsible to pay to
get here and we're not gonna put you up
no and but that's why you get yourself a
car you get that like when I committed
to it in 1995 I knew I had nothing else
going on nothing else I failed in
marriage I failed life I'd been to
prison I couldn't go I had come to an
agreement with myself about my drug
addiction but I knew that I wasn't gonna
succeed in anything else this was the
only shot I had 75 hours a night times
five is 375 a week guys if it was to
drive around not have a responsibility
have a pager to live in my car and go
for whatever dream I had at the time
that 375 was worth it believing that and
that includes gas and in those days they
wouldn't give you a hotel but you still
have a cover those three nights that you
didn't like a lot of rooms a lot of
nights you go somewhere it's a Tuesday
but Wednesday's open but hopefully you
meet a dude on Tuesday that says hey man
tomorrow night I'm looking for a feature
in 50 bucks would you ever like trying
to get a giggling even
I mean anybody would go to a bar and be
like hey can I do comedy here and take
the nothing you wouldn't do that not
that embarrassing okay they might throw
you the [ __ ] out but I'm saying you
gonna do comedy at a bar right okay in
that comic that host there he's the
radio guy he'll tell you come back in
two weeks and I'll give you another gig
but you didn't know that until you went
there
that's is they're not gonna tell you
that on the web page and I'm gonna tell
you that you know there's a comic in
town a camera his name he has a book of
that he sells to other comics with names
of Booker's across the country oh wow
that's Martin and I always felt kind of
weird about it because I you know they
come and go right
Booker's come and go but a market you
don't really know a market until you go
into that market if I want me say yo
this is how it starts you'll be at you
go to one of your open mics at Alta Dena
whatever the [ __ ] you do what's the
Whitewater knowledge oh you gotta get
like the library and there's a dude
there from Indiana and he knows you from
the podcast and he starts talking to him
he has 30 minutes and his home club is
whatever the club isn't Indiana and
he'll tell you Lee if you ever want to
come out dog I'll get your [ __ ] MC
weak base three hundred bucks you get
yourself out there
300 bucks ain't [ __ ] but when you go out
there Lee you're gonna see you're gonna
get the 300 bucks but it's an investment
you're gonna meet people
one comics gonna take ya you're not
gonna sit in your room you're gonna go
out and after every show in those small
cities they have another comedy show
somewhere and the guy will give you his
phone number they go next time you come
back call me and I got a I'll have a
Sunday night and a casino and I got a
Thursday night gig which picks you up an
extra hundred right I guess so now next
time you come you get a raise and you
get money from the back end and the
front it's very interesting but the same
applies to any job any anything that you
want to do with your life you're not
gonna know it's there until you go there
right it's like trying to find an
apartment you know if you're trying to
move to LA and we're just looking online
for apartments you wouldn't know you're
not gonna find them apart
cities you got to get the car and drive
around in that way you don't know what
you're looking for right my wife found
the house down the block from here while
going to look at another house parked
over here
yeah and she walked on when she walked
back she the lady said I'm I'm renting
up here and this is why we're sitting in
this office my wife came to look at
something else so nothing you never know
where you're going until you get there
that's the beauty of this I want to
cover something tonight it's a Monday
morning podcast light podcast we got a
great [ __ ] week we got a great lineup
in August but I want to talk to you guys
about something something gotten a lot
of emails lately I didn't know how this
started or how this ended I got a bunch
of emails I guess when Theo was on
Rogen's podcast that last time or the
time before they had a conversation
about me checking in okay yeah on the
phone I check in with the oh when I
check in with Joe and Joe said yeah Joe
is one of the guys that does that and
I'm a getting a lot of emails about it
and it's like I don't know it seems like
people are blown away by it I don't I
mean it's a something that I've been
I've noticed for years and it's the
other night wouldn't I
we might have had taken mushroom that
texted my best friend from high school
and I went to I was in his wedding but
we talked probably three times a year
no I don't like most your if it's a very
rare thing these days even even my
parents used to do when I was growing up
but now I don't think they do it as much
what's that talk with each other it's
there with Facebook and all that it
that's what it's turned into it's just
no no but I mean I had this thing go
from as a youngster you just learned to
check it people tell you when you're kid
I check in come on and check in me and
swing by say hello let me know if you're
eaten let me know if you need something
that's what that means check in tomorrow
check it check it check in you know and
the problem is the reason why I check in
with people
the number-one reason is and especially
I learned it from doing Tom
Olinda from being the salesman that give
a get calls from people they only call
you when they need something all the
time yeah I'm guilty of it too
it sucks yeah it's really nice to get a
call from somebody that just says hello
wait till you become a full-fledged
feature act and you just call a book to
just say hey Matt last time I worked
your club I had a great time thank you
or you become friends of them you start
calling them and you don't ask him for
work and it's like a hooker well that
you don't ask the [ __ ] it drives him
crazy because everyone else in the world
is doing that everybody calls him for
work I would call Booker's say hello I
don't man help you well he watch the
Lakers last week we [ __ ] up the
[ __ ] Rockets [ __ ] didn't we you
know and they would they would get off
the phone
and then when Rogen would headline their
club they would say something to jump
Joey Diaz caused me ain't anything like
a more were you hoping that they'd call
you eventually or no no they I had
already gotten work from them right
I had already them in the bag I always
just thought that has a Booker even as a
comic you get to feel like a [ __ ]
people just call you when they need some
it's very like I became like okay the
guy who really started me in this comedy
thing here was a guy with the name of
Dan and he ran the Brahe improv
I remember Daniel was my [ __ ]
[ __ ] Dan called me this is when
two people [ __ ] like me in this town
Joe Rogan and [ __ ] Dan Dan ran to
bring him properly and he told me I want
to bring you down here just for you to
make me [ __ ] laugh
and one day Dan called me when I was
down and out and Beverly Hills guys I
mean down and up and he was listen man
I'm trying to start this new thing you
Tommy used to be Tuesday through Sunday
in this town so take Monday off yeah so
Monday you would fly back basically on
Monday morning land at 11:00 go to your
house do
three feed your dogs go we want you
check over here
Asian the Commission and Tuesday morning
you'd be back at the airport and you'd
be at a little problem on the Tuesday
you have a show on Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday we're the bigger only showing
us - yeah - Friday to Saturday and one
Sunday ah this was it and then the big
name is backed up to Thursday through
Saturday entirely there was a wife that
was a time I remember doing two shows a
night were Richard Jeni selling out
Miami every [ __ ] night to own up to
it and then three on Saturday he walked
out of there with a hundred and forty
thousand dollars this is this had to be
God rest his soul
this had to be 1998 he gave me $1,000
tip I thought I was gonna [ __ ] die
nobody had ever given me a tip and I
realized then later somebody said he
walked one hundred and forty thousand
dollars it was two four six eight eleven
thirteen shows that's ten thousand I
show you something like that he walked
out of there Wow
like you just destroyed him for a week
like something crazy back then which I
think that's what it was maybe 15 grand
the show I don't know exactly but you
know that's a long week and he would
come up with an hour and a half every
night and he'd switch up a half-hour
everybody was [ __ ] brilliantly how
often would he do that would he do that
every week he would do that at the time
it Richard Jeni was working pretty much
three and a half weeks a month he was
doing cruise ships for big money like
back then he would go on a cruise ship
but he was getting he huge paychecks
like it was crazy but he wasn't really
happy and I remember talking to him at
the at the news cafe and Coconut Grove
the old we used to go there for
breakfast deliciously they give you a
baguette and cut it up for breakfast and
I definitely that [ __ ] yolk good
butter that's how I got the way 400
pounds of [ __ ] so anyway and I
remember talking to him and he wasn't
happy about you know the stand-up
that at that time stand-up was booming
like it was every [ __ ] day I would go
to Miami for three weeks in a row as a
feature act do you think the Internet
almost kind of ruined it cuz now people
have stuff to do at home is that like
what you know hey listen people are
still coming out right yeah calmly you
know people are still coming out for
comedy but back back to this check of
anything because it really it really
baffled me that people didn't believe in
it and that people had never heard of it
before I listen I check in in the
mornings with a rotation okay I have
rotation with Timmy Holloway George
Collard in ski Jimmy V my friend the
[ __ ] senator Buneary lubes you know
so I have a rotation there I have my old
Colorado rotation my Kessler you know a
DZ oh I got a bunch of people that I
still talk to that just we just still
talk and we talk about the weirdest
stuff and when we get off the phone you
know I still talk to Dominic know who
called in to the show I just talked to
him two days ago on the road the cop
that called him from the FBI Wow I
become friends with people it's really
weird how you know well have you ever
asked them like but this did try to call
Bob Lingus for a week and I always
forget Chicago time oh and I knew he was
on vacation last week you know I talked
to Bobby Sharon called I don't have a
[ __ ] call you know you always try to
the weekends are rough because you're on
the road the weekends are up cuz you're
on the [ __ ] Road and at the time for
some reason we sometimes they'll say one
missed call so I just think Lee called
and then two days later I'll see that we
call I missed a call from you and I
missed a call from somebody else but it
just says one missed call
I'll where I was wondering are you have
you ever talked with George or Tammy or
any of them and said do you guys keep in
touch with us yeah and Jimmy talks to a
lot of people Jimmy we all
from that cut Wow we all came from that
cut you know you have to work on
friendship that's what people really
never really understood everybody that
always looks for 20 friends you know you
have to work on your friendships the
same way you have to work on your
marriage couple we scrub along the road
to Vegas and that's why I tell people
all the time you know what man we all
have skeletons in the closet you got to
check out them from time to time they
want so I gotta take a skeleton out and
break that Scout than that you know I'm
saying it was 20 years ago it's time for
you to take that skeleton down and pour
some [ __ ] lime on it and figure out
what really happened and the week that I
was at in Vegas for some reason I was
riding I was just writing a freestyle
for the book I was trying to put
something together and I really really
really thought about the situation with
my ex-wife
it was really weird it was then like
going from A to Z I don't know if you've
been there that you're thinking about
sports and next thing you think you're
thinking about your girlfriend in high
school about something happening you
gonna do an event and I just thought
about and I told you guys that I told
you guys a comment last week that
there's a few people who saw me at my
worst and she was one of them you know
like the like you really don't know
anybody do you see them at their worst
that's when you really get to see what a
person is about and she got the [ __ ]
Beauty to see me at my worst when I was
at the worst human being I could
possibly being a couple all the people
so slowly that I still talk but she was
one of those people that saw I mean she
saw it from the inside out she saw six
years of it that I'm not too proud of
and will have herself for some reason I
was I had I was writing in the iPad like
the book like just and I ripped out my
notebook and now I have a notebook why I
write daily stuff it like what's on my
mind and I went to a chap that had been
anything and I wrote her a letter well
as weekend or completed oh yeah
couple weeks ago I wrote her a letter
man like apologizing for my behavior and
just for the things I just it just in
guys let me gaze on you said commercial
I will CD and you see the way they make
up a bunch of sandwiches no I haven't
see the stupid commercial bus and how do
you control your OCD and now you see
this girl cutting up a [ __ ] lettuce
and she's cutting up a [ __ ] tomato
and all since she makes like 52 [ __ ]
sandwiches you know because she's
obsessed with this thing it was like the
the apology was coming out of me and it
was like I couldn't control my hand I
was writing it out you know and I wrote
all the bad things I had done in front
of her the drugs that just atrocious
things I had done you know and and
there's times I sit here and I say you
know what I want to kill her for what
she did you know what man after 2 weeks
ago I realized she had every right to do
what she did because she saw me at my
worst and and it takes a lot for
something to say that that she saw me at
my worst I mean what's my worst shackled
in a [ __ ] jail cell to [ __ ] 20
other guys shackled by my ankles and my
wrists connected by a chain that's the
worst you know what's the worst seen me
in a room after I haven't gone out for
three days doing cocaine and my hair is
greasy I can't imagine myself with
greasy hair she saw me with oil in my
hair after three day you know [ __ ] like
that you know she saw me one day after
Court yell things to her that no man
would ever say to somebody I said the
worst things it was like the worst day
it was like all the [ __ ] I had in me
from all those years of suffering from
my mom I unloaded on her in front of her
husband or at that time her boyfriend
and the detective that had arrested me
on the kidnapping thing because he had
she had called him up for him so I
helped her testify and how bad of a
person I was or she went to that but it
was so funny that I it was like a
four-page letter and he just brought her
and we didn't plan on letting that
happen
no running back I apologize for
everything I did
front and back I [ __ ] him went
downstairs I got an M below oh you sent
it no I didn't sent it okay I [ __ ]
wrote it and
I went outside that day I smoked to join
them that the [ __ ] thing on fire oh
[ __ ]
yeah that was it but at least I got it
out of me I pull out the universe I got
a lot out of me you know it was
something I've been eating away at me
for [ __ ] 20 since 1994
have you written letters before I always
write letters Lee I love writing I love
my iPad but I love the art and the gift
of writing when I write and I write
freestyle like that and I tell you that
this notebook not this particular one in
front of me but the notebooks in my
house have been my psychiatrist the
notebooks in my house of my psychiatrist
for some people people always say oh oh
wow yes i chi chi's when you go up on
stage and top and tell the audience no
it isn't it's the [ __ ] I write down
because I've written down everything
I've written down everything it's the
weirdest [ __ ] it's like that way that's
what happened that day with how I got to
my wife I was writing about I got I pick
a subject and I just went off on a
tangent to something all right we got
had a podcast one day and I went off on
drugs and a couple people got mad at me
cuz I went down a foxhole with cocaine
and then I went home and I actually drew
like not that that day like a couple
weeks later after I thought what I had
done when I was in Vegas I was thinking
about that I was thinking about
something she said to me when I called
her four years ago three years ago two
[ __ ] for her to call my daughter
back and she knows I told her the
effects of drugs and all this stuff and
I kind of battled it off like here we go
you know blaming the [ __ ] drugs again
and I'm trying like they just I hate
when people blame [ __ ] drugs for
whatever I did I did what I did because
I did it not because of [ __ ] drugs
you know let's knock it off that they
did contribute they did contribute a lot
to the behavior but I did what I did
because of what I'm
feeling you know i retweeted a thing by
Bruce Lee the other day that a man who
doesn't know himself you know I didn't
get to know who the [ __ ] I was and what
I stood for so after I started stand-up
do you think you Billy how you know oh
[ __ ] we all think no no what we Walt
yeah we all think we know who the [ __ ]
we are right and who the [ __ ] we are
what makes us then we don't know
death to dick and one day it just all
clicks it's like when you're a [ __ ]
break until you ever hear like a movie
The Italian Job
whenever the hot-looking chick yeah
would hit the safe there we go whenever
she would hit the [ __ ] joint that's
what your mind is like it just takes to
hit it like I started calming anything
in 1991 so what was i 28 29 I was 20 I
was 28 years old remember I told you for
two years I did comedy and I had no idea
what I was doing right so I didn't
really even so I'm telling you guys
right now 295 was when I finally was in
the ballpark so that's 32 now you got a
consent I'm a [ __ ] loser you know I
got a GED all that [ __ ] so that means
you guys could do it by the time you're
27 you guys are all five years they
haven't me let's just pretend let's just
[ __ ] pretend you know but I don't
think so I think we all you don't really
nobody really gets it well do you think
it changes maybe like you're a different
person at different stages of your life
so you kind of have to find each stage
abso-fucking-lutely
absolutely I [ __ ] this is why I do
not like what's going on with the me too
like I was thinking about Papillon okay
Papillon is a movie that was buying
today I was watching something with my
daughter and I think Papillon means
butterfly in French okay you know and
there's a movie called Papillon with
Steve McQueen and Dustin Hoffman and it
won Academy I think it won Academy
Awards I'm not sure it's a great mood
they remain it would with Jax teller oh
wow okay Jax Tosi if you find the
trailer for a Papillon with Jax teller
but it's a great movie it's about it's a
prison movie [ __ ] the [ __ ] one with
the black
guy in a white one the shawshank
redemption' knife you don't like that
one I never even saw that okay I've
never seen the it's probably not what
prisons like well it's also old-time
prison i watch bits and pieces of it
it's not for me I don't know what it is
but what the [ __ ] we'll be talking about
Papillon Papillon see when it comes out
well came out in 2017 it came out don't
tell me that movie came out already
yeah wait what was it released I'm
trying to find out no no no I was made
in 2017 that movie cannot have been
released yet
if that movie's been released oh you
know you're absolutely right I'm sorry
it's coming out in August August 24 who
the [ __ ] you think you do I don't know
why I am DB says 2017 for no cuz that's
what they filmed it okay god I thought
it'd be is no filming okay well Papillon
is a great [ __ ] movie
I don't know it's the original won an
Academy Award Steve McQueen was great
but the guy on the side was Dustin
Hoffman but his legacy is getting wiped
out because of the foot rub incident you
know like on all that [ __ ] now if it's
something you did two weeks ago I can
understand that but if you're gonna come
back on me from something I did twenty
four years ago number one I don't think
that's right and number two I tell what
else I don't like about it that you're
your livelihood is gone without getting
judged by a jury of your peers you're
just getting judged by one person it's
your word against mine well that that
part is scary but like where do you draw
the line Lily how long does something
matter like how long does it
it matters forever you're always liable
but you know what
call me call me first and say hey man I
think I'm lame before word that you were
a little bit out of bounds but for you
to go to AP news now and say this what
do you gain by it
nobody [ __ ] remembers nineteen thing
before I'm the only idiot that that goes
there because I want to bring myself
there from time to time to see how I
felt that when I write a book or when I
read a joke or just you know but who
remembers 1994
you know six seven so that's what I'm
saying like they were accusing him
something be done the set to in 2000
we're all different people let me tell
you something I've been I got honestly
look at you and tell you I was five
different people my life I think every
10 years or something I guarantee you I
still meant being the skid like not
having any dreams not thinking I could
ever amount to nothing kid and then I
remember having a little hope and just
being like a junkie thief and then my
mother died I'm gonna be just like those
10 years were just sad and then I
remember this other kid that was just a
[ __ ] dad like an admin and then I
remember like a me starting copy that I
mean with those first couple of years of
me a war my ex-wife and I was still an
animal dressed in sheep's clothing and
had already been to prison and I was
still a [ __ ] animal I mean I I
struggle with this sometimes because I
was I must think as I as an ex-convict
you must get judged a lot from stuff you
did and I'm like sometimes if I if I
would go online if I heard some girl
that I knew was dating a guy who would
just got out of jail it's like what is
she thinking like that but like I don't
know where you're supposed to draw the
line I don't know where you're like yeah
they are a bad person or oh they made
one mistake and why are we judging them
it's kind it's kind of where did you
grow up you're like oh maybe maybe I
shouldn't look down on these people
coming out of prison coming out of
making bail the first time was one of
the most difficult periods of my life
because I'm walking around thinking that
everybody knew what it happened right
even people didn't know me like I think
walk into a supermarket and have a funny
feeling this guy was looking at me weird
because my name came out in the paper or
something like that
it really changed the game for me
mentally I'm not gonna lie to you and it
changed it on levels because then even I
looked at it as a joke what was a joke
well you know I had done something bad
I've gotten in trouble and if you guys
want me to lie to you and tell you but
like after the after two months when I
realized what I had done I went back to
being Coco like I just didn't give a
[ __ ] and it was like a joke like it was
like a joke any was like meh - I have
been ashamed to tell anybody it's the
truth it's the mental state I was at
that time with the drugs and the whole
[ __ ] deal it was like a joke for me
like I'm a boy from February of 88 till
August 15 when I got sentenced 88 like
it was like I was living this [ __ ]
fantasy way I'm like I was gonna get
myself out of it like but that was the
first time I really started trying and I
could see that I could do something with
my life that's weird about it like
looking back now you know I just
remember getting that letter like I'm on
bail and I get this letter from the
University of Colorado like a while on
bail okay this is like again you guys
always say well you're Joey you have no
idea what you thought about with the
universe I'm out on bail I can't sell a
car I can't make a [ __ ] living you
know I'm living off a little bit of
savings I have put away I'm I'm eating
conservatively I thought I had a
girlfriend but I really wasn't going out
my roommates sold coke so I stole it
from him and every once in a while I had
what $20 worth the [ __ ] cocaine or
something like that oh my what I wasn't
saying it was in Tamil when you were on
a bale hay bale and one bag of weather
like here I am this [ __ ] huge loser
everybody knows what happened you know I
can't get a job at the car business
I know what if any Goreski Colorado and
they're like congratulations mr. Diaz
we've just been writing who we're
reaching out to you to inform you that
you are not uh you are not allowed to
take classes at continuing education
anymore that you either have to transfer
to a a higher college I don't know how
they worded or the University of
Colorado
I'm like wait a second wait a sec what
do you tell me that I can't go that now
it was like so you you're asking me to
apply for the University of Colorado so
there was a number in the bottom and I
call this lady or whatever and I'm like
this is Joey Diaz whatever and she's
like yeah we got your credits from Rocky
Mountain College that you went to in 83
and 84 and with the last two years here
we've got all your credits and you have
enough credits to transfer into a
university you can't take any more
credits you have to start taking those
classes that matter like Jasmine yeah oh
yeah well that's like and I had a couple
history classes like basic math like
intro to economics like [ __ ] like that
that's the [ __ ] I was taken while I was
doing coke and selling cars and being
crazy I still always took six credits a
semester with no high school diploma no
high school diploma you [ __ ] moolies
I just went there life of me I got a
diploma once I got arrested and I came
out on bail there's a criteria list and
if you have that criteria risk covered
it makes your sentencing easy and one of
it was having a GED that's why I took my
GED the priorities but I mean so you're
so so the whole world feels like a whole
world's against you but the whole world
was against me but here a major college
is asking me to enroll in a college and
did you feel bad because you knew you
couldn't so now it's February okay huh
do you immediately know I can't do this
I'm going to jail I immediately knew I
couldn't but I go I'm not going to jail
I'm going to college I just made my
Imjin I just I just told the biggest lie
of my life to myself like bigger than
comedy like that was the first time I
[ __ ] lied to myself well now I'm lied
to you that was the second time the
first time I lied to myself was when I
[ __ ] I told everybody my god my
stepfather's even give me money from my
mother's estate I knew he wasn't gonna
give me that I just said to myself to
make myself feel good
we lie to ourselves to make our fear we
when I got that letter from the
University of Colorado are you [ __ ]
kidding me
who's going to prison I'm on to college
I'm back to school like Rodney I can't
go back I can't go to prison I can't go
to prison I'm going to college
I called that lady immediately she goes
come down tomorrow pick up an
application it's a minute with 35 hours
or $25 whatever the [ __ ] it was 25 hours
and I submitted it and yet I submitted
my [ __ ] GED thank God I had taken it
like I took the they took they made me
go to a class like three Saturdays in a
row okay from 11:00 to 3:00 just to
review it and then you take the test
only a [ __ ] [ __ ]
only a [ __ ] could fail that [ __ ]
passed for free for free some school
just said just come in from 11:00 to
3:00 on Saturdays and we'll go over
everything that's gonna be on the GED
and then the fourth week you [ __ ]
take the GED and I pass I got my high
school cool and see the coma and so I
three weeks later I got a call from
Colorado come on down I go down there I
give them the paperwork I got my little
[ __ ] equivalency diploma is [ __ ] and
no one looked at the data they don't
give a [ __ ] about nothing then that's
all about the Benjamins baby ha ha true
so I give them all my [ __ ] and now I
even called the attorney I go listen
done you ain't gonna believe this we
ain't goin to jail he's like what are
you talkin about
you got rid of the victim I'm going to
college he's like what are you talking
about
and let me tell you what I'm talking
about I got 26 [ __ ] credits all these
years why everybody thought it was
[ __ ] around
I was accumulating credits like a
[ __ ] like ask Allah that i am taking
intro to this enjoy of that and [ __ ]
he's like are you crazy but you're onto
something because this could save you so
I paint everything I had to get
transcripts from high school sent over I
had them [ __ ] do all this [ __ ] and
baboom they told me no no they said no
no no but but see what I did the
paperwork for some reason I don't know
what happened I had in one of my white
moments I didn't mark
Brannock Oh what did you put I don't
know Italian no like white I don't know
I don't [ __ ] know what I put on there
and the guy called me back his name was
James Jaramillo I stood I looked him up
hereit just recently retired cuz I
wanted to thank him he called me up and
he goes if you were a more Hispanic in
that box and we'd do a couple things on
your paper I could probably get it to
get you into the sea you old Pete
College Program [ __ ]
what's Opie a minority of the program
from blacks and Latinos and all you had
to keep was a [ __ ] like 2.0 average
and they'd throw a thousands of dollars
at you and I was like sign me I'm gonna
[ __ ] that boy do I check the box even
better yeah that's the truth that's a
true [ __ ] story guys home and I
gathered to the University of Colorado I
picked all my courses I did one course
like they they had this me do this one
for week intensive like three nights
like Tuesday Wednesday Thursday writing
for college it's not to get me ready
like I did that I was ready to go I
wrote a letter to the judge I wrote a
letter to lip-read probation department
now when you get sentenced to prison
it's not really the judge who sentences
you you know that right
he has litigations and he has a bunch of
things
it's the probation department that
sentences you uh-huh
there's a thing called a pre probation
investigation at least it was word when
my day guys the big thing for me was my
interview with the probation lady my
attorney got me prep for that they
[ __ ] it hire the chick who sat with
me that cost me like 125 an hour for
like three or four hours and prepared me
for my meeting with this probation lady
we hired when we hide the program
probably investigated he'd the dog has
all work on issues from New York City we
grew up like four blocks apart yeah look
up the evil Robin yeah my attorney was a
bad mother
so we do that we did a whole work and I
went in there but I didn't claim
liability and that's what pissed her off
then I dropped our conversation she
liked me and she said she [ __ ] she
said that I would never ever ever
probably get in trouble again but I
would never commit recidivism but I
would never get in trouble again but
that I haven't get spanked because I
didn't understand what I had done member
I told you I thought it was a joke Jesus
that's a lot of power
yeah but I'm very happy she did that no
really you're happy yeah put Tony
Bennett up then I guess for shout outs
my man Bret yan my girl Destiny's down
there [ __ ] Salt Lake I'm sorry I
didn't get the weed from you Eric Andre
cash Donovan Tony Jack Matt's my man
Dominic Silas thanks for coming Adam
damange James Benson and Bhosle bellows
no but I got a note in here somewhere
what the [ __ ] did I put it that's for
you thank you I've heard great things
about Utah so it's awesome to hear they
got a good time even people on the over
mic shot could tell me that this open
mic at that club is great it's a comedy
[ __ ] powerhouse of the town they're
dead love and comedy I looked at that
lineup they got a great lineup I want to
do a special Happy Birthday shout-out to
my men Matt Lamas I know it's your
birthday I think Tuesday [ __ ]
happy birthday I got to you from my
clients so I didn't forget about no body
but it's not it's a great time it's
becoming uh you just got you'll see over
the years you go to these places and you
see the building you see the comics s
star coming there
and you get you hear different rumblings
and people like brother it's a good
[ __ ] room and that's a great room
it's a I mean I was blown away I was
blown away even Vegas was great like
Vegas the South Point was great
[ __ ] great both shows were packed
great you know I took a little long time
whatever I was going through took a long
time I'm happy I'm back but back to the
[ __ ] checking in thing that really
got me that nobody it's so weird
okay so this I don't know if you guys
know where we live we live in Southern
California so as clubs in San Diego this
club's in Ontario now this is coming up
from Mexico up so first she had San
Diego and this is clubbing Ontario then
there's like where Rogan was this
weekend pollute by collusive Casino a
Pachanga Pechanga and then you have like
the Irvine Spectrum comedy club then you
have Brea and then you have Hollywood
right then you have the Hollywood area
and then you have the valley where we
are and then you have Oxnard and you
have the Chinese restaurant mentor and
you got that's it you got the ha ha
North Hollywood inflaming you got all
this stuff when you play the clubs on
the South Bay like either Brea Irvine or
Ontario it's really weird what happens
to your Facebook you start getting hit
up my comics from that area and first
they hit you up with a simple question
or hey how you doing with stinger by the
end there and then a week later they hit
they go right for the jugular and they
go was wondering if you had a feature
spot for next week no I you know have
nobody you just sit in it and even if I
didn't have nothing I wouldn't give it
to them just for the sense of how they
did it
are you following me so let's say you
had a gig coming up in two weeks down
there do you expect like alright the
Thursday before I'm gonna get a call
from this guy I do you know now who's
gonna call you and one know if you
called me all year every month and said
hello right
I'd probably call you and give me that
gig anyway gotcha did you follow me I
know who's gonna hit me up for something
just by that first email or Facebook
message instead of email me throughout
the year and having me involved they
email you a week out and they hit you
with something weird hey I saw you on TV
the other day and then they hit me with
that can I feature for you on this date
and then insults me because they're nice
kids
insults me cuz they're nice kids he's
just doing it all wrong
it's so weird how I'm doing after the
the Netflix special comes out um they
give this a tour and then I know the
comics I'm taking out and taking you out
on a couple days Jorge Perez
Erik I can't Quigley I got Dean del Rey
always D'Agostino I liked these young
guys I put him on the podcast for a
reason I've seen and now I've watched
him grow like when Theo first came on
this podcast he was a headline that I
was struggling now Theo was a [ __ ]
headliner you know now Theo had his
doubts a couple years ago three years
ago we were Theo Theo was going through
his own personal demons look at the Oh
today what do you think changed he was
in his head he was using drugs and he
got cleaned up any guy loved his head
the drugs would give him like a social
thing the same thing I still have you
know but it takes time you know you see
these people like that like Erik Rocha
last week for example I think Eric's a
funny funny guy Lee I think he's a very
very funny guy
he's made me laugh on nights that I
can't I'm at the fourth wall waiting the
[ __ ] stabbed myself in the [ __ ]
eyeball and he had wines of a life said
to myself for the last six months what's
this kid doing here
he should be in laws clubs on Sunset he
should be at the Laugh Factory at least
every night
chillin close without the [ __ ] dirty
shows because he has no fear Eric Eric
Roach has no fear he'll follow me I
approach isn't your father
and I know that about him I see how bad
he wants it I see who he is a disciple
of I see who he watch you know when you
know here's a guy that doesn't want to
hang on the comedy stuff and when he's
ghost encounters so he actually pays and
pays and watches comedy
he's done it a few times since I'm known
he can actually call me and go can you
put me on the list and he won't do that
he'll pay the 25 bucks to see Doug
Stanhope or don't even come and see me
and pay for the original remember one
night turning in the original name he
was your birthday Shelley I almost [ __ ]
my pants you know I would have put him
on stage I liked them back then I just
didn't really know how to approach him
but once he has said to me that guys
like me you don't like him
it really ate me up inside because
that's not what I'm about I like funny I
like funny problem I like funny I'm a
fan of [ __ ] funny I got into this to
laugh
I want to laugh I want to laugh my even
if you bomb sometimes somebody bombs
this is funny in single or using me bomb
hilarious when I borrow my bomb in style
nobody bothers about a little joke I
take it like a man I know I'm bombing
sometimes you see something the worst is
open mics when somebody thinks they have
a good joke and they're bothered there's
so many different levels of bombing and
there's so many different levels of
funny I've seen people bomb war
hilarious is that the weirdest thing to
say because they barn funny
Brody all right yeah absolutely
Brody Stevens I know bro I know Brody 20
years when he was doing that and people
looking at him like what the [ __ ] is he
talking about
I still remember him in Gig Harbor
Washington summer of 96 me him and Josh
wolf and him stopping in the middle of
the act and saying how come there's no
brothers up on the wall because there's
no Jews up on the wall because the whole
stage was headshots and frames and in
the middle of his act he looked at the
wall he goes hey how come that's not
Jews up here I'm not coming back to Gig
Harbor so I see it you appear and he was
looking at the three Jews that were on
there and he's like they're not real
Jews like you know you see the
progression of these calm
and do you think the people who are
hitting you out for Brea and all that
aren't doing this sort of work they're
not progressing no they just wait
they're waiting for the Bluebird of
happiness to knock on their door listen
when you're a feature act you have to
work every like matte full Tron matte
culture on is a [ __ ] machine isn't
that his name
yeah he's the machine every time I talk
to Matt for trial he's stuck around the
machines part the machines Bret he's
with the full charge I give him like
he's doing DC and Philadelphia with me
oh cool that we could tell yeah that's a
great show because I know he's in the
East Coast it's a train ride for him he
doesn't give a [ __ ] and he gives me and
he works at any level some we see them
they're all like all those guys are on
with cusps they can feature and they can
have mine including Kate Quigley
including Dean Bowery the I heard Dean
dower was phenomenal I want to give him
a shout-out Dean there was phenomenal up
in Montreal this week Congrats buddy
Congrats to Dean del Rey I mean I swear
we had you know we had him on the show
what four or five years ago I know a
hustler I know the difference between a
hustler and I [ __ ] con man cuz I was
bought a boat so do you think the reason
why people like Eric might not be at
those clubs is just because they don't
have a name yet like if that's
absolutely Eric just average his life's
about to change
I'm taking them on their own deletion
among people and people gonna run out of
those fans
cuz he's gonna hit him up he's gonna
learn how to feature he's gonna be a
good [ __ ] feature he's gonna be very
fun he's gonna put it together and then
I think I know how to handle him in the
midwest in st. louis 3000 again that's
what makes me laugh are you gonna not
make a make a buggy like you have to
tell the no I don't I don't dog I don't
do nothing to people that's not my gig
I'm not if you come to me and ask me I
may give it to you because I know you or
I may not say a [ __ ] word to you then
when they go we're gonna let that joke
go ray what do you let it go ready how
many times I have to [ __ ] bomb feed a
buck let the jungle by now you know I'm
one of those guys
don't say nothing to yourself hanging
yourself until you come to me when they
think that when they fire me because
what you under that juggle by eating
dogs the guy don't want the guy's a
[ __ ] that you know the guys the [ __ ]
of that you want to keep doing because
sometimes you pick a joke and we'll go
to war with it on our own merit because
that's who you are as a convenience you
love it someone you love it so much and
your ego thinks it's overpowering but
the joke is just got off when I'm the
king of that I've done it for years I
listen to all those CDs a city oh but
it's all checking in is all a part of
salesmanship it's letting the people
know you care for them you know that
that thing that that that kid that
practice or whatever that printed that
thing weeks ago it was from reddit and
it said why all these guys like me that
he they couldn't figure out with all the
things I had done that why did these
comics look up to me and all that [ __ ]
you know I still have a card from REI my
war from like 1998 from him thanking me
that card means more to me than any TV
show and he said you know in like 2008
when I was thinking about quitting
comedy I was talking to a friend of mine
2009 before I got the podcast and
businessman Felicia and he said that a
lot of comics looked up to me young guy
so I should start talking more to them
they spoke to Rizzo and that's how I met
Johnny Rock and all those guys you know
when I got back and how I got back into
Connolly was true young guys sort of we
did with the fourth wall he means
degraded you yeah Agostino
right yeah D'Agostino we've met each
other on the same analyst biggest really
yeah yeah we met at the ha we all bet
the same right well no we you you
probably need the ice you know a little
bit before that but I met both I meant
to say my both of you the same time yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was weird
the Agostino brought me back he got me
ready for the Gabriel a [ __ ] show and
then I had mercy the CD you know they
like this and that was all without the
store that was at the store that's why
now I dis
I'm just doing company at the store
that's it that's it
because you got so far without it buddy
flow you can talk if just listen you
know what men I belong at the store I
even told Shibuya - so Tripoli on the
way out he goes hey I want me to do
Sikkim likely you know what bro for
right now I'm going back to my original
rule I'm missing two spots at the store
and on the road and my little little
fling I got my little residual the pain
I got up dead the Icehouse my little
residential working out with uncle Joey
once a month or once every other month
or something like that in between big
shows or some see stay active and learn
the hour but I'm not doing comedy
anywhere else at home how long that much
time listen starting August 13th she's
got to be at school late a year that
means if I get home at 11:00 I'm not
gonna be in bed till 12:00 to 1:00 I
gotta be up at 7:00 whether me and my
wife in fact we're gonna start running
it this week so she's ready that week
that she's off because there's no will
last week at camp so she's in regular
school now yeah she starts regular
school in the 13th so I'm running this
game a lot different starting on the
13th this game has to change I can't be
out later than together you've already
you've already seen all the others you
need to see I mean I'm fine I'm still
gonna do my Tommy why are you doing my
thing but but you don't need to go to
different ones like I do know that's it
I'm just gonna go to the store and be
where I belong that's why I belong
that's where I belong
that's you don't push me metal sharpens
metal you know metal sharpens metal make
sense it's free interest I like all the
other rooms but for me they'd go on the
road and do what I have to do metal
sharpens metal you know you want to get
good at jujitsu got I'm gonna go bring
you you gotta go to our Berto crane or
you gotta go to John Chuck oh you gotta
go and everything else is mediocre but
when you come to me and you go listen
you don't want to go in the UFC
well I want to [ __ ] start competing
[ __ ] for big contests - you pick one
of those three it's our bird okay bring
it or John John child you know up here
you know
else is going on all over the country
I'm talking about app you know you have
great schools in Orange County and all
that stuff and probably by the pier you
said I gotta train up in this area
Pierre it'd be cab ringin doesn't he
train prefer breezy over don't you know
I know John Jacques trained a ton of
people I mean I know I learned from one
of his [ __ ] Black Belts who's
brilliant Bret's one of his black belts
who's brilliant so so is true jujitsu
and Bakersfield Matt Baker John
Jacqueline's unleashed a bunch of but
that's what I do so for me to be the
best I can be
I gotta be on the Tuesday lineup at the
store every [ __ ] week with Ron White
which euro can follow in Euro can follow
and you know Sam Tripoli following the
league is to follow Chris D'Elia you
didn't know I have what I see I have to
follow Chris D'Elia I just took the
sword in my [ __ ] neck you're gonna
follow and Chris D'Elia is like that's a
clean good-looking guy I'm in no danger
what do you remember it was our time
where you felt like you had to go up
multiple time tonight oh yeah I did it
all the time and not even not even to
get better but I just meant like
sometimes like right if I have an actual
show that I'm doing I always do an open
mic first just to get the rust off yes
yes absolutely and I like that's a
that's a hardest part for me when I see
you going into a Thursday or something
Monte's that must be hard to go and cold
no I use Thursday as my world will warm
up okay my Thursday night show in the
city is my warmup I go out Wednesday
night
I like this weekend why not Wednesday
did the Comedy Store with Joe on
Wednesday and an idea what I wanted to
do I can only run 20 minutes and then
that least Thursday that I'm not cold
that's cold that's cold to me a days in
butt ugly so Thursday on the plane I put
together my slit list the [ __ ] I wanted
to try what was up in the air what's out
there there's stuff that's out there and
then Thursday I go up there I probably
do like an hour then on the weekends I
cut it down because you got to move the
people in and out the two shows are sold
out but I try everything on Thursdays
there's days of your warmup night once
you get into that big week like you know
like that like that's what I use a fork
what do you ever when you were like
touring what are you trying to find it
open mic in that city or no
when I was touring I did everything I
could wait I don't know I don't know
what you thought I did every set there
was that night to do cars trains planes
and automobiles
I didn't I never did the New York scene
but when I started and I my first three
is of serious comedy two years were
Balder and that was I had a drive I had
to go to Cheyenne Wyoming some nights
the weekends
when I got to Seattle Monday night it
was he calmly underground in Tacoma
Tuesday was to come the underground and
there was like a Vogue art bar that
there was girls dancing in cages and you
had to go up in between and do ten
minutes and you were in a big big bigger
depth and they gave you three drinks
that's what we've been Frankie the nose
that's for me and Josh became friends
with Frankie the nose the guy we rob the
safe with and all that [ __ ] then
Wednesdays you have a specialty show at
the [ __ ] underground but Laura
Crockett had a room and so did Donna
Richards so you called them up and got a
guess that from them so I would have
three sets on a Wednesday night
I learned that hustle learned when you
get into commie it's about sets it's
just sets your first three years
it's just sets sets I don't know what
you're talking about Christmas I don't
know what you're talking about
no years I'll hopefully talk about you
know but then again your first three is
nobody's hiring you know the weekends
all right
so you have the weekends you basically
work Sunday through Thursday like an
animal unless a club gives you like that
local club makes you a house and see or
gives you haven't see work
there's only no work for you at that
level do you think that's like because
I've heard you say for a while that you
know you're not a huge fan of people
starting here in New York and but do you
think that might be the only benefit is
that you have open mikes available you
to you every night you have open mikes
available but the quality of the open
mics is [ __ ] that's also true they're
[ __ ] this [ __ ] and everybody wants to be
a star the mentality is different the
mentality is a lot different than an
open mic here than in San Francisco then
an open mic in Minneapolis
because everybody's going to work the
next day and ain't nobody talking about
NBC or go on the [ __ ] Montreal
nothing so you really get you focused on
comedy the smaller markets I don't like
these markets because it gets you it
gets put people in places they shouldn't
be at they shouldn't be at it just put
you in weird positions it's good for you
to see what the major leagues is but
it's also good to know who you are here
you don't know who you are people
telling you to get headshots I heard
that the other night Joey Diaz one stage
and I heard the other night uh Erik
Rocha one on stage at a steak house and
he got signed by CAA you know wait
that's it's a different thing it's not
you know people just trying to be
[ __ ] the funniest and they can you
try to open up for this guy you're
trying to do this there's always a
backhander E in those little markets
first of all you go to your place
you know how is it very fortunate I and
I never forgot Jimmy a-beta Jimmy Whelan
those I love I love champion with all my
heart
Jimmy's a goofy [ __ ] whoa but I love
Jimmy Mexican power out of Denver one of
the hardest-working comics I've ever
seen in my life if it wasn't for Jimmy I
would not be here right now
he's one of those comics and that is in
the top ten of people that helped me out
Jimmy knew how to producer ropes him and
handy Peyton a very important in my life
me and Keith Stubbs we're talking about
handy paid I've never ever ever seen
anybody repeat and he painted in my way
what he did he told the establishment to
go [ __ ] themselves and he did his own
thing and he did it his way like Sinatra
and it worked for about five or six
years but it was a lot of work for him
and I wish that I was experienced enough
I don't thank him enough like I don't
think I can't thank and he paid enough
because there was a guy but not billed
bloomin wrench up in Boston there's a
dick Doherty
yeah Emerson for a while okay so big
bowerly was like a see room guy yeah it
was in a bank vault right and he had a
bunch of different rooms and he cheated
people and stuff like that but if you
asked your Rogan who helped him out the
most in Boston it was battery because
dick Dario didn't give a [ __ ] out there
do you want
you know nobody wanted to work for dick
but dick made Joe a [ __ ] comedy you go
to Jerome
last week the dick Diary help you I'll
tell you immensely because none of the
other comics were over or he died key
and they didn't like Joe or Joe's comedy
was didn't fit their style or whatever
you know for me my dope dick Doherty I
had and he paid Jimmy a beta and [ __ ]
one of the guy that was a motorcycle
mechanic and those three guys were
responsible for where I am today because
I was in New York doing what you're
doing now
and it just sucked dick that's not her
it just sucked it multiple I don't give
a [ __ ] what anybody does it suck dick
yeah you and everybody's me and
everybody's got an attitude and
everybody knows this guy nobody knows
that guy it wasn't for me I navigated my
way through it don't ask me how
don't ask me how I was a junkie I was in
pain there was 93 I know how to hustle
but my comedy was a zero I was a zero
and it wasn't it was me and the scene I
was in was in New York I had something
going on and I was getting up onstage I
just wasn't getting on stage enough and
it was roughly it was heart wrenching I
was going through a lot you got to bring
five people to perform on a Friday you
gotta you know I had to make a living I
had a sin child support I had to pay
rent you know I had to do comedy arena
and I wasn't any good I couldn't wait
what are you talking about ten [ __ ]
years to get funny I need this now man I
don't need ten you ten years [ __ ] ten
years who's got ten years it's kind of
how I feel right now 32 [ __ ] years
old it's 1993 I'm 30 [ __ ]
years old I don't know anything I don't
know anything I don't know anything I
don't have a car I got no credit my
credit zero I got my car repossessed
I got nothing i got nothing i got no
banking I got nothing this is all I
[ __ ] got
I Drive a [ __ ] limo and I [ __ ]
snort coke and now you're telling me
that I gotta show up at five people
battling a four here so I can't go up
that type of [ __ ] oh you have no [ __ ]
idea and I said [ __ ] this [ __ ] I went
back to Colorado and I called Jimmy a
Boehner and he changed my life because
he had rooms every night at 40 people
Wow 44 those are you listening forty
people for a guy like me is like Madison
Square Garden I would love a square guy
I would love to do room in front of 40
people that 18 month period was so
crucial for me because my heart and my
soul were crushed because of what was
going on in my personal life but my
comedy was on fire
that was when I got into a stride Monday
night said did the Outback for
Steakhouse yeah it was called the
Outback it was the steak okay guy whose
dad did something else
Wednesday I did three things I remember
Sunday was one in dance class then when
she followed the wine dance class and if
I didn't have anything I went to a
coffee shop and the girl's boyfriend was
in the halfway house with me she was the
manager and she would sign me up on a
list for poetry night and I will go up
there do comedy they tell me to get the
[ __ ] out of there whoo boo it's not
poetry get off they would boo you [ __ ]
yeah they would boo me oh my god come on
we blog Dawg this the frat like I I'm
here today because of what I did in the
[ __ ] nineties
not because I did belong a shard not
because it did spider-man to think about
that
not because I did any of that [ __ ] it's
what I did from 91 to 2000 so think
about it no matter what you do no matter
what career path you choose you're gonna
have to suck dick the [ __ ] you're
gonna have to Harvey Weinstein it for a
while no matter what you do you really
do what business you start with you
started yoga business whether used to
you know what's the girl I got divorced
and you know did the tubs and the [ __ ]
you know people start [ __ ] and you're
gonna have disappointments but don't
give up the first 10 years of something
you're [ __ ] brutal and I didn't find
out about this so I started going to the
fourth wall and going these guys have
been doing comedy for four years this is
rough and there's been there's a couple
people that are right now who even one
guy who's new relatively came out I even
said it to the group you like I just I
tried this 20 years ago and you don't
want to be like me coming back and
starting over cuz you you gave up and
went you scared
oh don't people do it so that's crazy
and I fan you know what man I started a
lot of things I started a lot of things
and I quit a lot of [ __ ] things I'm
not gonna simple come on guys I quit
everything I couldn't I couldn't [ __ ]
him a [ __ ] hard day's work have you
[ __ ] paid me
I quit bartending I was a [ __ ] and so my
god I quit everything everything you
know I knew once I got into this there
was no looking back but if I quit this
yeah I would have felt terrible did that
coincide with what we were talking about
earlier when you like realized who you
were as a person like you're like it all
happened in 95 guys Wow a lot of things
just throw him to pieces I knew who I
was I know I was a junkie I accepted it
I knew I couldn't do anything else I
knew I wanted to be a comic
I knew I couldn't be a father I knew I
was a failure as a father you know
that's the truth that that's they that I
was a failure
and at the time you know that's why it
took me so long to marry Terry because I
had failed in marriage family and
marriage is so telling me it's it's
[ __ ] disgusting because you felt
because of communication you know why
don't people go well I got married too
young I got married for the wrong reason
you know that's it I got married for the
wrong reason and you pay for it that's
what happens when you do something like
that when you waste somebody's time you
[ __ ] pay for it and I paid for it
and today I still pay for board wing and
the only word on my [ __ ] shoulder and
walk around and pain that people see a
psychiatrist has done I wrote the letter
there's a head a little on fire and that
was it and I but before I was done with
this situation maybe six months ago I
come to the conclusion and then last
week when mercy lost a tooth
she lost a dude yeah that's where it
officially [ __ ] new Lana because I
never saw I was never with Jackie when
she lost her teeth she made it longer so
I made it longer so I'm good
I it all came full circle for me I'm
disappointed it didn't work out but you
can't but missus I watched that movie
Molly's game that that why they stayed
in my head that in this life you only
make it a couple good decisions and they
turn out to be great
you know I'm saying so stick with
whatever you have in your mind and thank
you very much for listening to the
Church of what's happened now don't
forget next week
I'm in [ __ ] Kansas City Missouri on
the 9th of Thursday night ain't o'clock
make sure you that [ __ ] Friday night
Rogen's in town I know you do and you
got to do what you got to do
you know Rogan hasn't been there in
years I understand but I'm there on
Saturday night so I'm ready to [ __ ]
rock you don't want to miss uncle Joey
I'm showing up with Dean Dell Rizzi and
then two weeks later HUDs
oh [ __ ] one show Thursday night and then
Friday Saturday Nashville are you
[ __ ] kidding me or what my niece is
coming we're doing the whole [ __ ]
thing it's gonna be great I'm excited
again I want to thank everybody for
listening for the podcast
I'll see your [ __ ] Wednesday I
got my main man Lee and don't forget for
the best supplements out there audit
from the shroom tech what do you think I
did before I got on the plane today
shroom take a mule
I get simple next to my Asian and ought
to put a mask on his hand he's he's
breathing on me trying to give me his
[ __ ] my look [ __ ] that I took my
shroom tech [ __ ] a meal tip-top Magoo
I'm [ __ ] ready to go shroom tech
sport right now I'm digging the [ __ ]
milkshake that Mexican chocolate protein
powder is delicious give it a shot girl
honey dot-com and press in church bad
10% off your order delivered to your
door number two like I said to you
whether it's Matt's rash guards shin
guards boxing gloves Fuji sports.com is
the website for you guys they're
dependable the [ __ ] look at the
quality of the knees is phenomenal I
vouch for them to the end of [ __ ]
time because I see these young guys
pulling on my neck go to Fuji Sports
calm right now I'm pressing Church
fullfil for foam and get 10% off that's
how we do it [ __ ] again I want to
thank the flying Joe and I want to thank
you guys we'll be back Wednesday morning
ready to rock don't forget to check in
you got a couple people in your life
that you need to check in with a couple
days a week just say hello
what happened guess what you make that
[ __ ] day that's the most important
thing have a great [ __ ] Monday don't
forget to listen to do Vaughn and we'll
see you guys Thor Wednesday love your
[ __ ] stay black check that smoke
Emile Louie Lee
[Music]